Ukrainian authorities say that Russia
has launched another major missile
attack on energy facilities and
infrastructure several explosions have
struck the capital key of other targets
include the harif and Odessa regions the
latest strikes come as Ukrainian
military and civilian leaders warned
that the Kremlin is preparing for a new
wide-scale offensive as early as January
Russia's Relentless attacks on Ukraine
returned to the capital today plumes of
smoke rising in Kiev amid one of
moscow's most intense bombardment since
it launched its Invasion as explosions
sounded across the city residents rushed
to take refuge underground the cave
Subway has some of the deeper stations
in the world designed to act as bomb
shelters in times just like these with
the attacks forcing trains to be
canceled stations were still packed with
people seeking safety and solidarity
this man bursting into Renditions of
Ukrainian folk songs to keep spirits up
foreign
passing time and bomb shelters now
routine for many it's like usual soon
because uh
this morning I will call
I saw a rank of the sky and I I wasn't
surprised I just saw and I understood
that I have to go to museums
it's not it's it's not like a surprise
for me because so we were in this
situation it's more it's a real world to
hear about
three hours
I was gonna go home
Ukrainian authorities say Russia
launched 70 missiles across the country
while the majority were shot down by air
defense systems two people were killed
in the city of cleveria
said he was also hard hit with officials
describing colossal damage to
infrastructure attacking our energy
infrastructure making people suffer
during the winter time that's about
genocide of our nation but I must admit
that our moral is extremely strong and
we will never surrender
the attacks are unlikely to ease over
the coming weeks with Ukrainian defense
Chiefs predicting Russia will launch a
new offensive early next year that could
include a second attempt to take Kiev
DW's Nick Connelly is in Kiev he told us
more about today's attacks
we're definitely stand started with a
lot of bangs here in Kiev something we
haven't had for quite some time uh
seemingly that was the air defense
system here working but pretty close to
us in the center of Kiev this is a real
sign that Russia still has many more
cruise missiles and other options of
disposal than Ukraine would want we've
heard from the Ukrainian authorities
they say they were able to deal with
were able to shoot down about three
quarters of the missiles that were
launched against Ukraine today 60 out of
76 but it does seem that especially
outside of Kiev where the defenses are
better lots of strategic targets being
hit lots of power outages here in the
central key if there's still quite a bit
of power you might be able to see some
lights on behind me but holds words of
kieval without power without water and
is a pretty Grim evening here in Kiev at
a time where it had seemed like these
attacks were kind of quiet me down
that was Nick Connelly there reporting
from Keith I'm joined Now by domatila
sakuramoso an expert on Russian security
and development at King's College in
London it's good to have you with us
these attacks today that we've seen on
Ukraine's power grid on the civilian
infrastructure this all looks like just
you know more of the same that we've
been seeing from Russia how successful
have these attacks been so far
well I mean compared to a few days ago I
mean these attacks have have been um
only partly successful I would say I
mean also a few days ago they were not
very successful but some missiles have
indeed penetrated and I have hit certain
uh certain points which are very
important uh some cities have been left
or a bit in the dark so this is sort of
this Relentless attack which which has
an impact overall of the whole energy
infrastructure and sort of the civilian
population and also the industrial base
and the sort of the the ability of
Ukraine to continue operating
effectively but I think that you know
with the air support uh systems that
have been so far delivered and the
possibility that additional air defense
systems are are being sent I think
Ukraine is in a much better position now
than it was um you know a month ago when
these uh very brutal attacks uh started
yeah Ukraine says that it shot down 60
out of 76 Russian missiles that were
fired by Russia Today the numbers appear
to be improving Ukrainian air defensives
seemed to be getting better is that how
you see it
yes I think that uh you know the support
that they're being provided
uh so it seems that Ukraine is getting
slowly the support that it needs and
it's able to protect itself and much
better I mean of course we know that
some misses uh entered the area of Kiev
but overall I think there is a success
rate that reaches maybe 70 80 percent I
mean that's that's very high it's very
unfortunate because some missiles are
still coming through uh so of course
they cause quite a lot of damage uh it
is also important to to remember that
sometimes when these missiles are hit in
the air they can cause debris and that
can have also implications because they
can fall on the civilian population or
on civilian buildings so it is it is a
very dangerous situation uh but the you
know from the Ukrainian perspective the
situation has improved significantly uh
in relation to what it was you know um
maybe a month ago when maybe 50 of all
the missiles were able to uh to which uh
the original targets and an element of
military assistance that Ukraine gets
that doesn't get talked about a lot is
training we know that the British have
been training Ukrainian forces and now
the Americans say that they are going to
increase the numbers that they are
training here in Germany I mean what
will that look like
I think this is also a very important
development because they commitment from
from dates from
pentagon is that there's going to be
sort of this regular training mechanism
of the pregnant Armed Forces through the
security assistance group of Ukraine
excuse me
that is going to be carried out in
Germany and it will involve sort of
company and Battalion sized units uh to
carry out coordinated attacks in the
battlefield so that's really very
important uh it's not only some training
forces to implement or to carry or to be
able to
um to operate the equipment that is
provided by the United States but also
to carry out more offensive operations
and of course there is going to be
training for the use of the so-called
Patriot missiles which are going to be
very important you know to intercept a
Russian ballistic and cruise missiles uh
the Patrick missiles they are Advanced
long-range air defense systems uh that
uh that run out at high high altitude
and so they can be very effective at
hitting at uh incoming missiles at a
much sort of closer distance to the
origin so I think these are going to be
training of these Patriot systems as
well so that that is something very
positive from the Ukrainian perspective
that's true that's true I mean I think a
battalion of the Patriot missiles
requires 90 to 100 soldiers to operate
so they definitely will need to increase
the numbers in training there don't
Matilda the Sacramento from Kings
College London we appreciate your time
and your insights tonight thank you
thank you